cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor that's nora o'donnell's in
mayfield where the tornado damage is so
extensive people say you can't even
believe what you're watching nora good
morning i know you were there and you
were seeing it firsthand
yeah gail where i'm standing i mean it
just goes on for block after block just
houses i mean just totally destroyed
it's just
it's difficult to fathom how much pain
there is to among many of these families
one of the many stories to be told here
in mayfield involves a minister who
narrowly escapes the tornado the
reverend joey reed survived by taking
shelter with his wife in the basement
closet of mayfield first united
methodist church when they emerged they
found that much of the building had
crumbled around them and here's what the
church looked like before and after the
tornado hit pastor reid went back with
our camera crew to see the damage
yesterday and here's what he had to say
[Music]
we came out and i realized that i was
looking up
to see the
extent of the damage to the church i was
looking at the sky
south wall here collapsed inward and the
ceiling came in
the devastation around us is incredible
all of that was part of a molar organ
that was historic
you can see some of the the ceiling of
the portico here you can see where
that's falling in and the brickwork is
all over the steps
thanks be to god the parts of the
building that came down didn't come down
on us
i realized that it might be the last few
moments of my life on this earth and i
was very glad to be with my wife i know
her prayer and mine
was that we might be spared i was afraid
for my children what would happen to
them and how they would respond to this
my daughter's going to be married in
march
and i'm supposed to do the service and i
was thinking of that
quite a bit as the as the tornado was
bearing down on us
all i care about is the fact that the
most valuable possessions in my life my
wife's life my children they're all safe
and everything else is replaceable
the reverend joey reed is with us now
and
reverend thank you and i mean
the people i've talked to too amidst all
this despair feel blessed that they're
alive
it's
it's one of the qualities of living in
mayfield kentucky is to see the
resilience of the the populace
we had a service of worship yesterday
our bishop was in town our district
superintendent the united methodist
church is connectional and one of my
colleagues very quickly offered us a
place to come and worship
and i offered to make that worship
service something after his he said no
let's worship together and as we came
together we're in the season of advent
and because advent
contains those those four major topics
of hope and peace this sunday was love
the third i'm sorry this sunday was joy
the third sunday of advent was already
planned
and
we realized that we were going to have
to do some tweaking but when we looked
at the service we didn't have to change
very much how did you give a sermon
about joy amidst all this
there was one surviving bulletin that my
administrative assistant at the church
had held on to the rest are at the
bottom of that pile of rubble that you
saw
on the back of that bulletin it said a
sermon synopsis basically joy is often
mistaken for happiness but happiness can
change by a turn of events
joy is something that abides and that's
what we're holding on to
you've also talked about how you're
counseling people you know one of the
families i talked to said they have no
savings they are on monthly disability
they have nowhere to go
how do you counsel them what do you tell
them about keeping the faith
well the first thing that we do is we
find those needs and we attempt to meet
those needs yesterday in that service of
worship our district disaster relief
coordinator bill carr was here bill is
one of those guys who comes in and
assesses the situation and sends groups
to take care of those immediate needs
moving heavy equipment into place and
he's all about trying to find those
bright spots how can we help how can we
make a positive difference we also had
our conference disaster relief
coordinator whose primary job is to
interface with fema the reverend robert
craig has been working with disaster
relief for quite some time and as a
result knows how to make sure that those
dollars are flowing to the right places
and spiritually spiritually that's where
the local pastors come in like myself we
are trying to help people understand
that as they move from their place of
suffering into their discipleship their
servant leadership it's it's we for a
long time talked about how discipleship
is forged in a crucible of suffering and
after that suffering is acknowledged and
that lamentation a word that we don't
talk about very much because it's an old
testament word for so many people after
we've mourned our losses and started to
let go of the things that mean so much
to us we can move into a bright future
where we're helping our neighbors and
that's what mayfield kentucky is about
there is so much suffering and
you know you just described it you're
supposed to be marrying your daughter
in the spring in in march and that's
about all i could think about in that
closet when the tornado was going over
please lord let me make it so that i can
see my little girl married
and
not going to be in the same church but
no the good news is where the service is
planned for elsewhere she's still living
in jackson tennessee
but
we've lost the sanctuary where so many
people have seen
that very event take place marriages
baptisms we've conducted funerals and
laid to rest so many of our members that
building was the repository of our
memories and we have to remember that
those memories still belong to us they
cannot be taken from us by something
even as devastating as this tornado
well reverend it's been lovely to speak
with you this morning and i know so many
people will depend on you in these
coming years ahead thank you for the
chance to tell these stories of
resilience i appreciate it very much
thank you pastor joey reed
now let's go back to you interesting
what he said about
so much of your faith forged in the
crucible of suffering
nate
nora thank you